well it is indeed a very somber birthday
for the queen of course the first
birthday that she will have spent
in 73 years without the duke of
edinburgh by her side
so a lonely birthday but she has not
been completely
on her own we understand that she has
been visited by some family members
today
the queen has two birthdays she has her
actual birthday which is today the 21st
of april
and then she has her official birthday
celebrations
in june which everyone will recognize as
truthing the color
so the birthday in april is always a
pretty low-key affair
and it's usually just getting together
with some family
that celebration is saved for june so
today is always a relatively
quiet day a low-key day but of course
today
is all the harder for not having philip
by her side
well i think we had expected a a new
portrait of the queen that is what we
usually get
on an official birthday but i think
given that the royal family is still
in a period of mourning it was deemed
more appropriate to
to reissue an old photograph that we've
seen and the other thing we didn't have
today was the 21 gun salute which
usually takes place
in london so i think both being quite
key indicators that
this birthday is being recognized it's
certainly not being celebrated
and it's very low-key well the palace is
understandably i'm
not going to be commenting on who the
queen got to see in terms of her family
today because this is a private
day and any visit floor has been private
but i think
it was expected that she was going to
spend some time with prince edward and
his wife sophie
and their children lady louise and by
camp james who were
all at the funeral and lived just very
close by to wins the castle
i'm pretty sure that prince andrews
who's almost a daily visitor
to see the queen at windsor castle will
have been there today
well there were some notable absentees
the duke and duchess of cambridge were
on an official engagement they'd been
given permission to go and see
an air cadet force squadron in east
london
the queen had said even though they're
in a period of mourning she's more than
happy for them to do that
and the prince of wales wouldn't have
been able to visit the queen because we
understand he's on a private
trip um at his cottage in wales he's
taking a little bit of time out during
this morning period so
um the queen did have some visitors but
it certainly wasn't
a complete family gathering well i
understood that prince harry was meant
to be returning to la on monday he did
have a flexible open ticket
and he actually left on tuesday but i
think he gave himself another 24 hours
in london now he didn't stay
for the queen's birthday i don't think
too much should be read in
to that it's not a snub the queen
doesn't traditionally celebrate today
as a birthday and i think the fact that
he extended his say
i believe by 24 hours is an indication
that he
obviously wanted to have some time with
his family now i think
that there were at least two meetings
with the queen one in the gardens of
windsor just before
the funeral and a further private
one-to-one meeting
between harry and the queen so this has
been an opportunity for something
of a family reconciliation harry's
incredibly fond
of his grandmother they share a very
close relationship it would have been
very important to him
that he got to have some time with his
grandmother before he went back to la
well you know this was of course a
private meeting and i think there's a
great sensitivity over any conversations
that are happening between harry
and his family members because
everything blew up when details of his
peace talks with william was suddenly
broadcast on the american airwaves so
as you might expect it's being kept very
tight
being kept very close no details of
these conversations are being leaked
but it is safe to say that there were
meetings with family members
and certainly prince harry did have some
time with his grandmother the queen
before he went back to l.a
you